you've had your mom on the channel a few
times her advice was to listen to your
man and always say yes to him sexually
curious to see if the panel would take
that advice
so i'll take the [ __ ] down
my mom always said one of the reasons so
my parents have been married close to 30
years we i have nine siblings clearly
right
oh she was saying yes all the time
and that's one of the things she told me
she like i liked him it's awkward for my
mom but she was like to make like i
asked her like what are the keys to like
a long healthy marriage and she said one
of the keys like if you don't want your
husband to like step out is to just
always say yes because men have like a
higher sex drive than us okay that is
true but what if like one night you're
just tired and you're like hey babe
let's get it on he just said
because that's where there's like mutual
respect factor though
yeah like you need to know like when's
the time to please your man and do a
thing for him but like vice versa yeah
if you don't want it like that then it
shouldn't be a [ __ ] conversation it
shouldn't be like it should